you guys were in love until the end
right until the end I was doing The
Frighteners when he had the heart attack
you know it's halfway across the world
Australia or New Zealand oh yeah I was
back and forth four times in two and a
half weeks and everybody rallied around
me and got me through that took care of
my daughter I remember she was there
when I was practicing flying in the you
know in the harness and they made her a
little harness so she could go up in it
Michael would play Foursquare with her
so at the end of the brighteners you
know this was for business class flights
back and forth in two and a half weeks
well it would have been more I think
than my whole salary and I went in to
pay it off and the bookkeeper looked at
me and she said this is Peter's gift to
you he's just gonna absorb all of this
and that's the kind of guy Peter are you
kidding